if there are a bunch of friends who can
just like sort of text each other on the
weekends regarding ideas that they have
and you don't necessarily have access to
that pool then it becomes extremely
jarring there's no secret that the tech
industry has a little bit of a culture
of a being a boys club have you seen
that how is that played out in the
places that you've both work it's a lot
of these relatively young guys who
started you know companies without any
professional training and it was like
hey I'm coding with a bunch of my
buddies who do I know has credibility in
this area and credibility was a function
of how well do I know this person and
you know that's one of the reasons
that's contributing to this very slanted
toward favoring like a lot of men in
this industry also being women who are
from a technical background working in
tech right you don't always see that
what do you say to the idea that while
there just aren't enough women out there
they're not looking hard enough
well there are women coders there are
women in the industry but I think a lot
of them get overlooked because you know
again it's this it's this old boys club
right but there's also this you know
there's this idea in the tech industry
that a lot of what the tech industry
does is based on this meritocracy right
like like it's you know what you do not
necessarily like what you present but
the reality of it is is like that that
meritocracy it still has this set of
rules that's like that's based on what
people perceive of you and the
perceptions of a woman who might speak
and act in the same way that a guy would
she gets a totally different sort of
perception of who she is in comparison
to you know a man who might speak and
act in the same way that that she's
trying to speak she
is direct and you know to the point a
lot of guys interpret that as you're
angry you're aggressive your race
evasive you you know where as a man who
might know might speak in the same tones
using even the same words he's thought
of this like oh he's a go-getter
what is the difference when you have
let's say a female manager in my
experience you know I've had it both
ways right now I'm actually really lucky
to work for a company where almost 30%
of our engineering team is women which
is unheard of the first time in my
career I worked on a female dominated
team and you know like Laura said a lot
of the emphasis on you know cooperation
and sort of communication and being able
to relate to an one another they just
tear each other apart isn't it just a
catfight no oh it's so different so
right now I work for a company that I
think the staff is like 90% female and
it is a world of difference you know and
other tech companies that I've worked
for where it's been more male centric I
learned to just sit there and listen to
the entire room and never say anything
unless I knew 120 percent what I was
talking about because yeah you'll get
you'll you get capitalized on big-time
yeah and I think that the fear of
judgment and evaluation is so severe and
because women are conditioned to be more
fearful of external opinions I think
that it can be really intimidating
Silicon Valley is saturated with not
just men but also extremely brilliant
minds and people who come from all sorts
of technical backgrounds you know but a
lot of the barriers that manifest
themselves and women sort of holding
their opinions or ideas back has to do
with inclusivity right so when it comes
to the clustered problem of a lot of
guys just hiring their buddies right it
becomes sort of this casual friend group
where the communication channels are
lubricated with that friendship and
sales though they're already established
and so if there are a bunch of friends
who can just look sort of text each
other on the weekends regarding ideas
that
and who knows you don't necessarily have
access to that pool then it becomes
extremely jarring right what advice
would you give to a young woman starting
off in the tech field if you can really
sort of renew your intention as to why
you do what you do right and really keep
your eye on the prize so to speak I
think that it really sort of helps you
stay focused on on the goal that you're
eventually trying to achieve you know
who you are you know the value of
yourself don't let all of that noise
from the outside like confuse that or
defocus that for you